estamos saliendo de la región de kiev
estamos en una estación de servicio y
podéis ver la cantidad de familias que
están abandonando
la capital son cientos de coches colas
kilométricas en las carreteras por los
puntos de control y por la cantidad de
gente que se está marchando la mayoría
de ellos viajan a la frontera con
polonia muchos tienen familias en los
pueblos aledaños porque hay que recordar
que los hombres no pueden abandonar el
país así que bueno sobre todo intentan
escapar de los bombardeos que están que
están siendo cada vez más intensos y que
se espera que sean más intensos durante
las próximas horas